foreign
[Music]
is still considered one of the most
successful Pixar movies of all time
totally deserved the film also won the
Oscar in the category best animated
feature at the Academy Awards it was all
the more surprising that nothing about a
possible sequel to the film was made
known for years but a Disney's d23 Expo
last year the time finally came and
Inside Out 2 was officially announced in
it the story around Riley and her
emotions will continue to be told in
today's original we take a brief look
back at part one and tell you everything
you need to know about the sequel
let's take another quick look at what
the first movie was actually about we
experienced the birth of Riley in the
start of her emotion headquarters from
now on the emotions Joy sadness fear
anger and disgust work together to take
responsibility for Riley's actions and
Savor Memories the really important
memories are stored as core memories
which form Riley's personality this is
made up of for example family honesty
ice hockey friendship and fooling around
however all is put to the test when
young Riley moves with her parents from
rural Minnesota to San Francisco after
sadness touches on a memory on the first
day at Riley's new school she begins to
cry sadness also causes arguments with
Riley's parents whom she accuses of
being to blame for her distress in an
attempt to salvage the situation joy and
sadness are conveyed into the Labyrinth
of long-term memory with them the core
memories also vanish and so the two must
try to find these again in order to
preserve Riley's personality a Race
Against Time begins as they both relive
Riley's childhood In The End by working
together they manage to create a new
core memory and Riley can be happy again
as we already know there is a decent
time jump in the new movie namely to
Riley's adolescence emotions Joy sadness
fear anger and disgust are of course
back but it's entirely possible that
other emotions will be added during this
exciting stage of Life at the d23 Expo
Pixar CCO Pete doctor revealed there may
be up to 27 emotions in the upcoming
sequel this he said is necessary to
portray the complex emotions of a young
teenage girl the plot will most likely
take place in San Francisco again and
will revolve around the complex
struggles that a teenager experiences
during puberty many viewers will be able
to identify themselves with topics such
as self-doubt physical transformation as
well as the first butterflies in their
tummies so it may well be that we will
witness how the emotions have to cope
when Riley is rejected for the first
time or hurt by a crush perhaps it's
also Riley who's upsetting someone else
and can't really handle it herself
nevertheless the movie will certainly be
aimed at a broader audience again even
though the first film was about the
emotions of a child for example the
connections between feelings memories
and behavior were universally relevant
if the creators put as much passion and
excitement into it again the years-long
wait for a sequel will definitely pay
off
at least as far as the original cast is
concerned there are some changes
although Amy Poehler is back as the
original voice of Joy Insider sources
indicate that Bill Hader and Mindy
Kaling as fear and disgust have dropped
out the reason for this is the huge
salary range among voice actors while
polar pocketed as much as 5 million
dollars the other two were barely
offered one hundred thousand dollars and
even though Disney wanted to raise their
pay the two declined with facts whether
the other dubbing actors will be back is
not known so far the cause for the
rather meager wages is said to be
Disney's new policy of savings when it
comes to animated films this has already
been noticeable in a number of Pixar
films which have been released directly
on Disney Plus instead of theaters such
as the story about the afterlife Seoul
the island adventure Luca and the
Adolescent film turning red the script
of inside out 2 is already written which
means that the animation process should
be in full swing by now as with the
previous movie the story was written by
Meg Lafave however there has been a
change as far as the Director is
concerned Pete doctor will be succeeded
by Kelsey Mann it was already gathered
animation experience on onward and the
good dinosaur for example we can expect
a first teaser at the next d23 Expo in
September but we don't know anything
more about it yet as soon as it comes
out we'll let you know as always
currently the release date for inside
out 2 is set for June 14th 2024.
and that was it all the information
about the long-awaited sequel to inside
out are you looking forward to seeing
the movie and what new emotions do you
think we can expect let us know in the
comments below and if you enjoyed this
video be sure to give it a thumbs up
thanks for watching
[Music]
oh